what's up marvel fans we're here with
simulu what is going on we're here at
the live carpet how does it feel uh it
feels pretty great i'm i'm not sure that
these people
realize that i'm not in this movie
i think they you know
i'm not gonna burst their bubble for
them no spoilers no spoilers no spoilers
at all anything is possible but i'm also
not in this movie
maybe
so
who are you most excited to see in this
film
um
i'm excited to see spider-man
no spoilers spider-man
question mark i'm excited to no no i
mean i i've been i've been reading the
rumors like everybody else i'm so
fortunate to get to be here to get to
watch this movie early
and
i'm just excited to see where they take
it i've been such a fan of the
spider-man movies ever since toby
maguire i think it's just been a really
long ride and a full circle moment for a
lot of people so i'm jazzed i'm excited
we're talking about that previous super
villains are in this movie what was your
reaction when you found out
uh i was pretty okay okay well first of
all i was like oh my god doctor octopus
is in the trailer and then i was like oh
my god like jamie foxx is there as
elektro and then it was like oh my god
he's got the stark tech on his on his
armor so i was like what does that mean
i feel like everyone was you know pretty
blown away by all of that i think you
know i i work for this company so i know
people at marvel they're master
marketers they're they're you know
they're mysterious they work in
mysterious ways they operate behind a a
veil of secrecy and shadow
um and and you know i'm just excited i'm
so excited that i finally get to take a
peek
behind and see what they've been cooking
up you know i feel like
i i deserve to be here because i used to
play spider-man at kids birthday parties
i dressed up i i inhabited the character
um
you know i was in the costume i i really
i feel like i was spiderman so in a way
i do feel like this is my premiere could
i still hire you for birthdays is it too
late um you can but the rate is now 75
000 an hour yes it's gone up a little
bit it's yes
thank you steve have a go let's take it
easy
[Music]
you